good morning yes you didn't expect to
get to this stage did you with this
prime minister
well i think after the weekend's
newspapers with very well informed
comment i don't think anyone's
particularly surprised that this has
happened uh this morning and the 15
barrier is a relatively low barrier
to achieve
so
i don't think we should be that
surprised by it
well it's 54 mps at least 15 as you say
of your colleagues have felt strongly
enough to write a letter about this
prime minister who won with an 80-seat
majority just two and a half years into
this parliament that doesn't alarm you
at all
well i think you would find in all
parties at all times there is about 15
percent who for whatever reason don't
like the leader of the party sometimes
uh it's ideological and uh we thought
barcelo would call for a return to the
single market so there is a strong
element of people who don't like brexit
would like to reverse brexit and feel
the prime minister
is the great strength and stay and
support of brexit who want to remove him
and then there are others
who are far from being gruntled for
other reasons
what other reasons
well you can work out yourself that
there are people who um have their
concerns there always are this is the
nature of politics um
leaders
are not like kim jong-un they don't have
every member of their party
supporting them fully at all times so i
i don't think getting to the 15 bar
is particularly damaging or indeed
particularly surprising i think it's a
relatively low bar
and fairly easy to get to
peter kellner formerly of yougov as you
know told us if a hundred rebels voted
against the prime minister about that
tonight then he is holed below the
waterline
well i fundamentally disagree i mean i
think um peter cannon is exceptionally
distinguished polsta
who i
think often has useful things to say
about politics
but in democracy one is enough and look
i tried this line
when i was
not entirely supportive of teresa may
saying she hadn't won enough and
actually everyone said to me afterwards
that was absolute nonsense and i had to
eat a good deal of my own words and so i
think the idea that there is a barrier
different from the absolute barrier
is false
and yet just a few months later she was
gone
well
between that time she had lost a vote in
the house of commons by the biggest
record i think uh in history so
yes indeed but that was because of what
went on in the house of commons it
wasn't a further reflection on the vote
of no confidence um and she also had the
conservatives
worst ever poll in the european uh
elections as you may may recall so other
things went
very badly wrong post that vote of
confidence it wasn't um a direct
consequence
how many conservative prime ministers
have long term survived a vote of no
confidence
well this system only came in um
post
1997 and since then there's been a
regular flow of votes of no confidence
um but
if you take a longer historic
perspective
you would see that there is always an
effort to try and get rid of leaders um
that people were conspiring against
margaret thatcher in 1981 and she went
on for
another nine years at that point the sdp
were over 50 in the opinion polls and
people were trying to get rid of
churchill during
the war and people had grave doubts
about israeli uh people were trying to
get rid of pit the younger um people
thought that when george the first was
succeeded by george ii he would fire
wall pole
it is the routine of politics walpole
went on for 21 years so i i wouldn't
focus on a narrow and particular rule i
would just
look at the generality of politics that
there are always people who want the top
job and a lot of people who've been
public in recent days clearly want the
top job for themselves and um they
therefore stir things up a bit and we
will see i hope the prime minister uh
win the vote later on today and then um
calm everything down
calm everything down there wasn't much
calm outside saint paul's cathedral when
he was being booged what's that
well there was a mere bagatelle
i mean little bit of uh booing a little
bit of cheering that is perfectly normal
i mean
politicians
a little bit of booing at the church
steps of a great cathedral when we
people were gathered there to pay their
respects to the thanksgiving
i think you over interpret uh what
happened political figures must expect
this bear in mind at the funeral of
margaret thatcher most successful
conservative prime minister electorally
there were protests um politicians who
do things politicians who achieve things
politicians who lead the country well
obviously stir up strong emotions uh in
certain sections of the population that
is what you would expect and and i think
that this sort of party that they were
on the steps of saint paul's is not
really reflective of modern british
society
well we're just going to play it anyway
and see what our viewers think and then
perhaps you can tell me again what you
think let's have just have a very quick
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
volume up to get your readers to be too
concerned about that that was a bit
miserable really
okay uh it's interesting you say that
because um i've been speaking to some of
your uh colleagues uh today and previous
colleagues who've suggested that that
was perhaps a turning point for some
who've handed in their letters over the
weekend you think that i suppose in your
words would be pitiful
well that's not a word i use actually
it's one more prime ministerial i think
you would find um but i think folderol
would be the word of choice for me
okay and why would you use that word in
particular
oh well i i think that anybody who is um
influenced uh by
um some muted noise uh that rather
excited a few journalists
would not be showing the judgment and
wisdom that you would expect of a
conservative member of parliament
okay in all seriousness i mean you've
been shunting our early doors today to
come out and support the prime minister
i i did you more than happy i
volunteered volunteered to come out
nobody has had forced me to come out to
support
an exceptional good forward-looking
prime minister
he's taking the opportunity later on
today i believe to uh address uh all
back bench uh mps what do you think he
needs to say in order to convince them
that they should offer them
him their support
well i think he needs to remind people
of what he has achieved um
and
uh as always beth rigby knows what's
happening before i do so um i didn't
know there was this meeting until
she announced it so as always sky is
very well informed um
but he needs to remind you of what he's
achieved
and the election victory was a very
personal victory there are a lot of
members of parliament who owe their
seats directly to boris johnson and he
has a mandate from the british people
and that is important we are a
representative democracy but mps are
answerable to their constituents and he
got a mandate directly from them he
should point out what was achieved in
terms of
the the coveted lockdown and getting the
vaccine out so that our economy could
open before anybody else's he should
point out the steps he has taken to help
people with the cost of living crisis
which are pretty thorough going uh he
should point out that he is leading the
way in terms of brexit which as i
mentioned earlier would be significant
at risk without his drive and energy
do you not think that they know that
already and yet at least 15 have decided
that he's no longer the right person for
the job
well the thing about 15 is it means 85
percent on the other side of the
equation
i said at least 15 percent mr i i know
more i know but it's still it's still
worth remembering 15 isn't that many
it also doesn't mean that 85 percent are
on the other side of the equation it
means that they just haven't uh put in a
letter uh that that that that's a fair
enough point but 15 leaves 85 percent uh
who one can assume
um at this stage have not come to the
conclusion that uh
they wish to get rid of it what
conclusion they come to later in the day
but they haven't got to the point of
thinking this is urgent and that they
want it happen now so i think it is
worth bearing in mind that 85
so far as far as we know have not called
for a vote or yeah i figure similar to
that because i imagine it's a little
over the 15 target
how many are much over do you think it i
don't know i don't know but just from
the speculation one has heard
yeah i i i'm just struggling in fact i
found it night uh the
letter that was sent uh by um jesse
norman today i don't know if you've had
an opportunity to read that but i mean
when when a former minister uses words
like
describe yourself as vindicated by the
report is grotesque talking about
the
queen's speech and elsewhere your
current policy priorities are deeply
questionable he goes on to say
you are the leader of the conservative
and unionist party yet you are putting
the union itself gravely at risk goes on
to talk about the rwanda situation as
well describes the policy on that as
ugly literally
no holes barred there what would you say
in response to some of those accusations
well um jesse points out that he was
energy minister and
unfortunately no proper energy
plan was developed so mr norman must
take some responsibility for that he
doesn't do so in his letter you must ask
him on romanda what would he do what is
his solution uh to the crisis that we
have with
small baits why does he think this is a
wrong policy what is he coming up with
the use of the word grotesque is clear
over statement
mr norman is a distinguished figure and
historian and you would have thought he
would weigh his words more
carefully but he seems to have
um
a boned pick not just with the prime
minister
but with the whole range of government
policy so
he is deciding that he simply doesn't
support the conservative manifesto and
and drive we were elected to get
immigration down we therefore have to
implement policies that will do that and
so i'm surprised that mr norman is
disassociating himself from the
manifesto on which he was so clearly
elected
you talk about him being considered
historian so i would flip that around
and say to you a considered historian
who chooses his words carefully
describes the policy as grotesque or the
i think he's great
i think he overstates his case and
weakens it thereby
it's rather surprising that somebody
like him should
use hyperbolic language who would have
thought he would be more moderate in his
phraseology because it's clearly not
grotesque he may disagree with it but
grotesque is an absurdity
how many votes this evening would you
feel would be too many for this prime
minister to continue on at and feeling
that he had the support of the party
oh one is enough that's the rule in a
democracy if you win by one you've won
and do you feel that if this prime
minister won the vote tonight by one
vote he would feel that he had an
appropriate mandate to continue on in
his role as prime minister
one one is enough it's no good saying
that the rules of the party um say
something and then behind it
unofficially there is some other rule
that nobody knows and is invented for
the purpose um i obviously want the
prime minister to get as big a majority
as possible i think that would be
helpful and it would close this matter
down
between now and the next general
election which would be good for the
country good for conservative party
but one is enough
so just to be clear if i was to press
you on this forgive me mr reese
if he won by one vote he would have in
your opinion a clear mandate to continue
on in his role as prime minister ms
burleigh to be absolutely clear the
answer is yes
are you sure
yes
unbelievable some might say if they're
listening to you uh this morning here on
sky news that you feel why should they
say that
if they won by just one vote that that
would be sufficient to suggest that he
had the backing of the party and the
country why should they say that he won
a majority of 80. he has a mandate from
the british people and the rules are
quite clear
bear in mind when margaret thatcher was
prime minister you had to defeat your
rival by a majority plus 15 percent
there was an extra hurdle
it was open to the conservative party to
write rules that put this hurdle in
but they did not they decided that it
was a straightforward up and down
vote
and i think it's
um
eccentric really to say that you have a
democratic system
and then you set another hurdle within
it if as a member of parliament you are
elected with a majority of one
you are that member of parliament until
the next general election when people
have another choice that seems to me to
be perfectly fair and how democracy
works
we have two by-elections coming up
fortnight on thursday the polls are
suggesting that the prime minister will
lose or the conservative party will lose
both of those
elect by-elections one to the liberal
democrats and one to the labour party um
is the writing not on the wall for this
prime minister
no um you know perfectly well the
history of by-elections that if you take
the period 87-92
where the conservatives lost by-election
after by-election in the 92 general
election if i remember correctly we won
every single one of them back people
vote differently uh in by-elections from
how they vote in general elections and
that is that is well known and you know
you can trace this back to
orpington the most famous uh post-war
by-election defeat of an incumbent
government that by-elections come and go
governments very rarely win them
actually the conservatives have only
gained three by-elections uh in recent
periods of office uh hartley poole being
the most recent one um lo and behold
under boris johnson's leadership
can i just extrapolate from what you're
saying there that you fear that you may
lose these two by elections
no i mean it's not for me to say the
voters must have their have their vote
and the candidates we have excellent
candidates in both places um
and uh we need to work hard to encourage
people to turn out to vote but i'm just
mentioning in passing the history by
elections where governments often uh
don't do particularly well in them and
then win them back at general elections
when people vote on different bases
uh just received a tweet saying anyone
who believes our country is stronger
fairer and more prosperous when led by
conservatives should reflect that the
consequence of not changing will be to
hand the country to others who do not
share those values today's decision is
change or lose i will be voting for
change and that's from jeremy hunt
well let's just swap quotes because i've
had a message from peter and brenda
yates um from just outside bristol who
say we wish to convey to you our utmost
confidence in our beloved prime minister
he must stay at the helm of our country
so i'm listening to people who live in
and around somerset um mr hunt lost last
time around uh and therefore he clearly
wants another go at it
okay so you'll listen to the people in
somerset but you don't really want to
listen to the people who are going on
the steps of simples
i will listen to the good people of
somerset who have great wisdom